all right so what do you think about
youtubers life spelling excluded no
apostrophe no no capital on the tea I
was actually asked you the same thing it
don't this is not the kind of game that
I'm actually interested in playing like
okay
like the Chandra is not one that you
would yes now it's not my kind of genre
because if I'm gonna play a sim game I
tend to prefer more large-scale stuff
like civilization or Sim City but in but
in terms of functionality it works it
also hits a little too close to home it
seems to actually emulate a lot of
actual legitimate things that we that we
do I think that there should still be
more video type of options and I'm kinda
I'm kind of iffy about some of these
ideas like oh you have to go study or
your mom will ground you kind of a thing
it's like I don't get how that even
works there's ah it falls into this kind
for for me it falls into this kind of
weird in-between space where it's
simultaneously like kind of cynical but
at the same time like not quite cynical
enough and and the what I would point to
in supporting that or or to kind of
where I'm going with that is that like
the some of the things are very
realistic like in terms of like it's
like okay you got you know you got 7,000
views here's your three dollars mmm that
it's like okay that's realistic the the
numbers like the actual like revenue
numbers are kind of are kind of accurate
in terms like us in terms of the the
views to direct revenue like like hey
that's those numbers are kind of on
point but then everything else is
inaccurate that it's like the fact that
anyone is offering you any kind of deal
at 7000 subscribers is or or or the me
games involving its social interactions
with people
for purposes that still seem to elude me
I may be collaborating and hiring them
as editors yeah that seems to be cut
like a thing that pays off down the road
you know so you've got things like that
but then it's like rent it's like Oh
rent is is $80 a month no it's like I
would if if if you asked me to like kill
someone for $80 a month rent I I would
probably spend a lot more time thinking
about it that I'm proud of because it's
like Inc I mean you know like that kind
of thing that's so so on a certain level
it is realistic but then it's
unrealistic about the the sort of
logistical scope of what that means that
it's like okay how do you make money off
of youtube and because this is a thing
that I've come back to a lot like back
in back when I was still actually active
on the V that guy with the glasses
forums like I would I had a little bit
of a negative reputation back then
because I was realistic about costs and
yeah and pay offs and people didn't like
that that I come in at be like like yeah
man I'm gonna I'm going to make it I'm
going to be I'm going to be like Linkara
and I'd be like you're probably not like
your realistic odds of you know you're
realist like here's the numbers that you
need to be looking at until you're
looking at sustainable returns because
you need to consider like okay what does
rent cost you know this like and and
what does it you know what does it cost
where you live what you know how much
does food cost how much do you you know
what else do you need to be doing and
the thing is like that's so often
particularly on that upswing
you know the until you hit the break
points and that the break points are in
fact a lot higher than most people think
like realistically the break point for
making even a like modest living on
YouTube is around fifty thousand
subscribers I got incredibly lucky you
know joining right plague writer and I
did yeah and getting a huge amount of
viewership and support that that even
today sadly does not exist for for
anyone new who had joined along with all
the new producers during the last big
talent drive and as and and you know as
a result I managed to carry that through
even you know eight years later but I'm
not like rolling in the dough here yeah
I'm it I make more than enough to live
on and even then I've had to supplement
it through patreon if I if I did not
have patreon I don't know if I would
actually be able to live off of my
videos anymore mm-hmm I mean and also
with that like you know a lot of you got
super lucky like not just like not just
the right place right time there's like
okay it was when you know not just being
kind of on the early adopter Vanguard of
this thing but also along with that was
this advertising revenue situation where
no one on either side of the aisle
really had a solid idea of what the
value was and so people were just kind
of it's like what what's wrong yeah they
were just kind of Rory like they were it
was speculative so the CPMs were like
really high because because nobody who
was buying the ad space had the data to
be like no it's not worth that we're not
we're not paying that for your ads you
know to run our ads on your site like
but then that happened a few like a few
years back like the data started real
like one you could see it once people
started getting the data the CPM started
going you know going down and it started
going down precipitously fast it came
back up a bit but it's nowhere near like
there was times when CPM was up at like
thirty thirty dollars
I never got a bad high but but but like
you know a very good month especially
during like the holidays which is still
[ __ ] is still sweeps Frodo yeah I was
like $15 gap CPM that was really damn
good during those not during the best of
times yeah and then it dropped down to
like a buck 50 yeah there was a reason
you know you know port port Lindsay and
Todd were grandfathered into the maker
stuff a blip did actually offer me a
contract
one point I was very tempted to sign it
my family looked it over and said you
don't get anything this is just a
terrible contract if you do not get
anything for it other than like a
guaranteed seven dollar CPM which wasn't
really enough to live off of anyway and
yeah and of course with the fluctuating
CPM still averaged out more than that
yeah there I mean it's it's really
complicate in the the numbers are so
oblique like figuring out for people
people asking about what CPM is it's
state yes basically amount of money per
one thousand views since under me layi
and four cents per Mille a yeah and the
and and you know people who do want to
get into this stuff I know a lot of
other producers are you know poopoo the
idea of actually becoming a video
producer the thing to remember is get
into it because you love doing it
because again we were incredibly lucky
we are incredibly lucky to be able to
make a living off of this but you'd
never enter into it with the expectation
that that's what's going to happen do it
because you love doing it I mean there's
there is another route
there is another route but this was the
other thing that I got super unpopular
on the the take would take forums for
talking about is that you either need to
approach it purely as a purely as a
hobby like you're doing it because you
love it and then if it meant just to
actually like make you a couple bucks
every month like cool you know right on
or or you need to like approach it as a
business activity like and that you need
to take it seriously as a business
activity you need to think about it
first and foremost as business and and
that kind of attitude of like hey you
know think like you're not thinking
about what you're making as art you're
thinking about it as strategic business
decisions a lot of people really didn't
don't like that attitude I mean because
it is kind of soulless it is kind of
heartless but it's like hey you know the
fine brothers are not big because they
really like
reaction videos they're big because they
are heartless and view it as a business
opportunity and unfortunately I think I
think a lot of us these days who are
doing it in terms of making money I
think of like game grumps and team force
are they are in the fortunate position
where they can do both yeah where
because they I mean again they were
early like and in a lot of ways like
they were early they were early adopters
they got that early you know
subscription lead yep but nowadays
because they have grown large enough
most of team four served money for this
kind of thing either comes from their
patreon or from their gaming channel
where they can monetize the videos at
work they can't monetize a DVD abridged
but but now they have basically set up
an efficient machine where they were
able to afford their own studio and hire
extra people to do the editing for
producing content that is churned out
daily so they know how to do it in a
businesslike manner while still having
fun you know with what they're doing
yeah but in order to I would love to get
to that point yeah I mean it would be
it'd be great to be able to hire a
person or rip the space ah like it would
be awesome to get to to get to that
point but I mean I think I think even
even if you approach it so if you
approach it as a hobby these days if you
approach it as a hobby and you but you
are consistent about trying to improve
your output improve your product like
you still at some level need to think
about it as a product or you're just
rolling the dice you're hoping to get
lucky you still need to basically get
lucky in some ways in a lot of ways but
you know you know you your odds of
actually like growing at least
organically do go up if you you know
take it seriously about getting better
like just producing better content and
responding to what you know what people
respond to and all of that if you
approach it like that like you can grow
slowly and organically and you can make
supplemental money
yep but I think even with that like and
and you can actually you can can get to
a point where you know then with patreon
like you can support yourself off of it
but I think beyond that like you are it
is it is so unlikely that you will ever
get beyond that if you don't then start
thinking beyond that yeah it can happen
but the fact that it is possible does
not mean that it's probable you know
that the you if if you dig into YouTube
you are going to find people who even in
the last couple years like not I'm not
talking about like the PewDiePie's who
got super lucky super early the jenna
Marbles like you can find people in the
last couple years who have managed to
get you know quite large quite fast even
you know today but I had you know if I
hadn't started taking you know a lot
more of this stuff seriously you would
not be seeing history of Power Rangers
on YouTube now me taking the effort to
not only re editing but rewrite them a
bit to make them better because I
recognize there is a larger platform
here and potential for more money and
more exposure so it's in my best
interest to redo them to the best my
possible ability and get more and you
know you'll create a larger level of
professionalism about it mmm-hmm so yeah
yeah it's it's complex it's complicated
I enjoy I enjoy web video though I think
it's a I think it's a good medium I
think I think they're all right here's
the thing that I think we get a little
bit too I did I I think I get a little
bit too cynical about sometimes and this
is actually one of sort of the core the
core points of my so I've got this
patreon stats analysis video that I
started writing like I did all the data
collection last fall and I started
writing it last fall and then yeah I
think I think I told I think I
contributed that to you were asking a
bunch of people about it weren't you
yeah yeah I was I was asking pretty
publicly and I posted snippets of a
bunch of the data and some of the
general sort of conclusions that I add
that I reach but one of the main
conclusions
that I wound up coming to in it was it
you know the the ship hasn't failed on
certain things the ship has sailed
you're not going to be the next
PewDiePie there probably won't be
another PewDiePie there won't be another
jenna Marbles they were emergent
elements of the the explosion of YouTube
that does not mean however that does not
mean that there is not the possibility
for success and I don't just mean like
paying your rent I mean like business
level success particularly once you
start looking at a platform like patreon
and how that interacts with the
ecosystem as a whole I think in that
area we're just seeing the we are still
in the early days I think the number of
people who are willing to pay into
something like patreon as a as a
platform who are willing to use that as
their content access portal I think we
are still in the early days of that I
don't think you're going to see
necessarily the huge explosion type
stratospheric support that PewDiePie got
through YouTube but you are going to see
people who are going to be able to build
industry a business sized support
structures through through those
channels I do like the fact that now
that we have something like patreon that
we now have a direct method of
supporting specific things that we want
to watch the pose you know as opposed to
just a you know rolling the dice on just
getting big or in case of or in the case
of our fan base hoping that they watch
you know multiple videos and things in
this case they have a direct method of
supporting creators and then and not add
those and not necessary like a set
expensive method because they can just
give a dollar and it helps
and what I'm wondering about because
especially because you brought it
actually cuz you brought this up the
idea of the explosion of the business of
it when are we going to start seeing
patreon a competition like other
crowdfunding monthly slash video slash
creation type of systems like it's under
the assumption that the world doesn't
and yeah due to external happenings I
have to be optimist yeah as we fight the
gonna fight everything yeah so if if we
if we assume that things are going to if
we ignore that and assume that this was
going to be a normal year you know I I
would honestly have expected to see a
solid patreon competitor by the end of
this year and I think that would
actually be about right in terms of the
timing because you had a subbable and
another couple platforms as sort of the
the early testbed for the concept and
then patreon is the first one to really
succeed and with that kind of a timing
you would then expect to see competitors
come out of that yeah and I still would
have under sort of good I think the
competitors that you're going to see
like it's going to come from two
directions I think you were going to see
another third-party competitor and we're
also going to see an expansion of
YouTube's a donation donation system I
think and also I would be surprised if
Facebook didn't come out with one that
sucked but somehow made money I'm
wondering if much like with YouTube
we're going to see you know competitors
rise up but then they'll either get sold
because you know venture capitalist a
thing or they'll get bought out or just
die and then there will be a monopoly on
it much like how YouTube has them
yeah days on video other thing I'm
curious if I ever see like another
YouTube thing rise up especially you
know you keep hearing reports about how
YouTube apparently is a big loss yeah
the main problem there so the difference
the difference between say the scenario
that YouTube is facing and the scenario
the patreon is facing is that patreon
has the advantage that it's a fairly low
cost like a fairly low overhead business
like there's a lot of data that they're
dealing with of moving around like from
point A to point B and interfacing with
credit card companies and so on and so
forth but compared to video hosting like
just the storage space alone like you're
talking multiple orders of magnitude
difference that that patreon is entire
data base uh likely fits on a single
blade of a single YouTube server like if
it's not even you're not even talking
about the same thing so just in terms of
like the actual cost of hosting the
service and and dealing with the traffic
the bandwidth cost of running the
business month to month patreon is is
far far far cheaper and so competition
is just easier the main the main issue
becomes those business relationships
coordinating with you know coordinating
with the credit card companies and and
building those building those
relationships getting those getting
those credentials getting those
permissions so on and so forth whereas
YouTube like anyone who wants to compete
to YouTube is automatically looking at
like minimum 5 million dollars a month
in hosting cost so that's like just to
start right also in suggesting you're
looking for the people who said very
nice things about me just getting that
out of there anyway uh yeah the cost but
do you think Google's ever going to be
it you know --gel wants to or is going
to be able to sell YouTube I don't think
they want to sell YouTube I think
they're definitely in a
I don't think Google wants to sell any
of their assets and the thing is is that
they don't have any reason to because if
you look at it Twitter their main
competitors and by main competitors I
mean they do like a tenth of the
businesses of YouTube their main
competitors are Facebook and Twitter now
Twitter is also not Twitter is not
profitable
however Facebook is profitable Facebook
and Google as a whole are profitable and
so really you're looking at the
competition between Google and Facebook
or Facebook is like okay we don't want
to embed YouTube videos because embedded
YouTube videos still play Google as we
want to have people use our internal
video hosting service so that we're
putting Facebook ads in front of those
in front of those videos and and that
right there is the reason like that's
both the reason why Google is ok with
YouTube losses because the net gain in
the rest of their services is worth it
they don't get me wrong they would love
it if YouTube was just self sufficient
that they didn't have to subsidize it
from so many different directions but
they're still willing to you know
they're still willing to subsidize it
because they do gain so much from it
another in other ways which is why
Facebook is actually trying to replicate
YouTube within their own minor version
of it because it's like it it is it's
it's tricky because it's not directly
profitable but it is incidentally
profitable like on like video hosting
video as content is so powerful at its
peak that it's impossible to ignore the
problem from a corporate standpoint is
that there is so much crap like that in
order to have that you essentially need
like in order to get
pekes you need an open platform the
problem with an open platform is that
you're going to have so much crust that
people are going to put on that it's
like you're going like think of how many
YouTube channels there are out there
that are crappy vlogs that are an hour
long each that have ten views and each
and every one of those is taking up
server space even if it's not taking a
bandwidth it is taking up server space
yeah and now once you get a one I mean
I'm sure you probably on the massiveness
is how much storage space must they have
when you think about just how many
videos must be uploaded on a daily basis
that need to constantly need access to I
you need constantly need to add new
servers just because of old content
that's taking up space I'm trying to
remember what it was but I think they do
a petabyte a day I think it's somewhere
it's somewhere along those range because
I know they were saying that the to you
that in so normally they publish the
data in terms of hours or like years so
they'll be they'll say something like oh
like two years of video is added to
YouTube every single day and and if you
backs all from that number then you end
up at about a petabyte I think that's
the number that I came that I came up
with the last time I I did that exercise
but it's been a while so I feel like it
was a feel like it was a petabyte a day
you know a thousand terabytes yeah and
like even if that is wrong like I mean
even if it is say 500 terabytes a day
like that's still a massive amount that
you constantly have to add I mean I'm
sitting by this point they've gotten
very good at it and getting it down to a
system yeah but just the massive amount
of new hard drives that need to be
installed and synced up to the rest of
their massive network
of data so that everything talked to
each other
cleanly and and can be accessed again if
say they need for some reason to access
the videos and be able to track it down
and criminy
yeah now the the thing is there was
something I was going to say in there
about the data the data storage and oh
right right right on the technology this
is why actually it kind we kind of end
up benefiting a little bit from from
that because as a result of that
situation like just the data
requirements Google is putting a lot of
money into R&D for superior compression
algorithms open like open access like
open source open access a compression
standards because the reason why they
want to be open is because if they're
open then they're automatically going to
be you know accessible to a everybody
which means they will quickly be added
to all of the tiers of video production
software which means that but it's like
they have a vested interest in being
like ok if we can't make this profitable
like we need to bring down just the
hosting cost we need to bring down just
the sheer volume of data that is
transferred so either we need to make
data cheaper or make videos smaller oh
god I just realized how it gets even
worse just in terms of storage and
maintenance see we we take for granted
the fact that they just have to store
the videos it's not just that they
probably have to mirror everything in
case one of the drives fails yeah like
it's all going to be like because you
have to get that data back up again or
else people lose how many or else how
many videos go down just from that now
like it's very normative on their their
data infrastructures is mind-boggling
it's
it's ridiculous it yet it exceeds the
capacity of human comprehension
Amy cats cat and we're in full-screen in
YouTube in a youtuber life why wasn't
there an option just make that I don't
know that was that that is definitely a
curious omission but since we're in
we're in full screen camera Amy Amy
there you go she doesn't want to look at
the camera she wants to look at the toys
on my desk there we go
I know vid me is trying to become a
competitor against YouTube I know that
will actually work but you know best of
luck to them because healthy competition
good thing mm-hmm who only live with not
on what was on its way to being a
competitor before before the before
before they got bought out well the I
mean the challenge the problem with
blitz was that their entire goal was to
get bought out yeah they were they were
not actually interested in the the the
people at the top were not actually
interested in in growing and becoming a
self-sustaining competitor with YouTube
and then you wound up with kind of a you
end up with a scenario where maker had a
deal with Disney or maker had
negotiations with Disney and Disney was
like well you don't have a hosting
platform so get a hosting platform and
we'll buy you and makers like okay we
need a hosting platform it'll be cheaper
just to buy blip and so make her bottom
lip purely so that they could then get
bought by Disney yep it's although the
fact that during the last month a blip
all my checks had like Disney stuff on
it first
all right well I think I think that's
good for this evening that was a good
night I know - yeah thanks thanks so
much for coming and hanging out Lewis
thanks know playing youtuber life with
me thanks everybody in the chat for
hanging out I hope that this was
entertaining and I think that end whole
bit
makes a great excerpt for for the
youtuber life and Amy Kat is indeed a
wonderful squishy cat so Amy she thought
she and thank and thank you for having
me and it's always great talking you man
all right take care everybody Amy say
goodbye meow